I think it's gonna take a very long time
I think it's going to take a very long
time because we're talking about a lot
of a lot of different communities that
that have had engines of education on
these things that would have to be
stopped and have to be a new way of
things has to be M inserted into them
the grassroots piece of this is is
interesting whether it is the the
professor that I met in Sarajevo or it's
the woman that I met in Kuala Lumpur or
it's the amazing sociologist in Morocco
named Fatima mooney see who you guys
probably have read but they're all doing
it in different ways but there has to be
a thirst from the person who wants to
hear has anybody done this that they're
going after that information you're not
seeing a global campaign or awareness
that says wow all these women around the
world are reinterpreting you know that's
not happening at all it's people who go
gosh I wonder if women have begun to oh
really there's that woman oh there's
that group there there's so it's
happening it's happening more your
generation that's why I brought up the
hit job in the city and the hit jobby my
chronicles because in the young
generation that kind of stuff is
happening really quickly people are
provoking every day if you go if you are
on any of which I am a lot of these
listservs for young Muslims out there
they're passing information left and
right about things that are happening
all over the place that's going to
happen in real time that's going to be
more more effective than the traditional
roots of analyze our or a you know
another institution like it